une première en france 2 hectares de
dalles démoli pour ramener au niveau du
sol tout un quartier c'est le pari fou
qu'a lancé le maire de vélizy
villacoublay pascal thévenot avec la
société sita llose le but donner à la
zone d'aménagement concerté louvois un
nouveau visage c'est un projet en fait
ambitions puisque c'est à la suppression
de vingt mille mètres carrés de dalle où
on va retrouver le seul naturelles avait
dans une zone habitée puisque
aujourd'hui vous avez 260 logements qui
sont sur la dalle des locataires est
donc le but c'était de faire rentrer la
forêt dans la ville de retrouver le sol
naturel du re dynamisation commerciale
qui était en fin de vie puisque
inaccessible et en améliorant aussi un
le confort des nouveaux arrivants comme
des locataires actuels
la fin des travaux de la zac louvois est
prévue pour 2020 ça va permettre de
remettre aussi tous les services aux
pieds au pied des habitations plus
facilement accessible et au pied de la
station de tramway puisque sur ce
quartier aussi ce qui est extrêmement
important c'est ce qui a été le
déclencheur du projet c est l arrivée du
tramway la création d'une station au
pied du quartier mais
face à cette offre de service
aujourd'hui la station de tramway les
difficile accès à difficilement
accessibles donc grâce au projet et
grâce à la déconstruction la dalle on
permet de recréer ces liaisons beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus facilement le but
aménager un nouveau quartier et les
travaux se feront en quatre étapes